[Music]
what really are the biggest xenomorph
variants and specimens if we include the
hybrids as well so let's get to this
video the 10 biggest of these scary
alien monsters
at number 10 we have the praetorian this
was likely the most prevalent and most
well-known variety of xenomorph aside
from the drone and one of the last
phases in the life cycle of one the most
recognizable characteristic was its huge
headquarters resembling a queens which
they used to ram opponents in a charging
attack it however lacked the second set
of arms that made a queen a queen but it
can evolve into one if needed this
xenomorph is 3 meters tall or 10 feet
at number 9 we have the hybrid king a
corrupted ai cult toy produce a race of
genetically modified hybrid animals
known as the white hybrids they have
characteristics of humans xenomorphs and
yautjas or predators the biggest of them
is the king which might be around 10 to
11 feet tall or 3 to 3.3 meters and
although nothing is known about the
king's function they appear to be the
species leaders
at number eight we have the deacon the
biggest difference between a normal
xenomorph and a deegan is the host they
come from and also the lack of a tale
the deacon came from a trilobite that
infected an engineer with its embryo and
even though the only scene we see of it
is as a juvenile that just came out of
an engineer it is thought that when the
deacon is fully mature it will be bigger
than its hose around 10 to 12 feet tall
then at number 7 we have the crusher
this is a variant of a warrior or a
praetorian xenomorph and was a hulking
beast that is more of a heavy unit than
a foot soldier able to engage even
armored vehicles with some success
this is considered to be the equivalent
of a tank with its headquarters included
the crusher can be taller than any adult
alien on all fours and could be 3.5
meters or 11.6 feet tall
at number six we have the queen the
mother and head of the cinema of hive is
one of the biggest forms of these aliens
and rightfully known as the queen
also one of the sturdiest and smartest
cinema of specimens compared to lower
variations queens have two additional
limbs sprouting out of their chests and
a massive headquest protruding from the
back of their skull a typical queen
measures around 4.5 meters or 15 feet
tall
at number 5 we have the predaline queen
this is a xenomorph spawn from a yautja
amongst the most notable results of the
xenomorph's dna
mixing the predalien takes more clearly
after its yautja hose sharing physical
traits such as dreadlocks mandibles and
a lighter skin coloration
the predalien from the movie avp requiem
is a queen juvenile and was 10 feet tall
but if given time to mature it would be
the same size or if not slightly larger
than a queen since it was born out of a
predator which is larger than a human
on the fourth spot we have the jockey
cinema
also known as an ultramorph that was
meant to be originally in the prometheus
movie but was replaced by a deacon the
jockey xenomorph of the altamorf is a
xenomorph born from an engineer
following the normal life cycle process
of xenomorphs it is huge in size far
larger than any typical human spawn
xenomorph or even a queen their height
is most likely around 18 feet tall
on the third spot we have the empress an
empress is an evolved form of a queen
alien a far older queen let's say they
are superior to queens often ruling over
several queens and their respective
hives empress physiology has been seen
to differ from queens
while retaining black and grey
coloration much of the empress's
features such as arms and head crests
are better developed and they are also
bigger at around 20 feet tall
number two the king also known as the
monstrosity of the rogue this male
xenomorph leader was a genetically
modified queen but can also occur
naturally in a very large hive such as
the one in their home planet xenomorph
prime it was larger and stronger than a
queen xenomorph but the queen was more
agile and intelligent so it cannot
defeat it but they are very large around
25 to 30 feet tall bigger than the
empresses and queens
and lastly we have the queen mother also
referred to as the royal giantess
dwarfing empresses and queens and kings
alike queen mothers have four arms a row
of sharp dorsal spines and a jaw full of
metallic teeth fitted with a deadly
inner jaw queen mothers rule hives
typically the highest they rule over a
massive cotton in or even planet-wide
and sometimes telepathically controlling
hives in nearby planets as well the
queen mother can grow to be around 50
feet tall or 15 meters hence being the
biggest xenomorph variant ever
and with that we come to the end of this
video so i hope you have enjoyed it do
hit that like button for support and
subscribe as well but most of all smash
that bell icon for regular updates on
new videos right here on this channel
till the next one take care fam